laboratory in osaka is home to some of
the most lifelike androids ever built
[Music]
and I had an appointment to keep with
one in particular
meet Erica she's the creation of Hiroshi
Ishiguro a professor at Osaka
University's intelligent robotics
laboratory mr. Goro has become famous
for his pursuit of a lifelike Android I
think this is the most beautiful face in
the world our challenge is to install
the intention desire to this robot so
without the intention there's our in
other Android it cannot be emotional and
under cannot understand other people
whose intention desires right
what kind of desires two's Erica ham she
want to be well recognized because she's
a kind of an exhibitionist for this
robbery her job is to be a receptionist
that's the receptionist or a secretary
or something exact do you mind walking
me through things she can hear
[Music]
Quoddy Massimo's but honest Emma's their
magic aha honeycomb Thank You mr. kinda
girl what happened she got angry she got
it I say you know I say the most much
much much this is a kind of joke all
right so you always say mushy much if
you're on the phone
right right right so it was brewed that
it's in person yeah Erica listens
through an array of microphones hidden
in the flowerpot and relies on
electronics and sensors for her movement
an AI software for her responses her oh
she thinks Erica lives up to the term
Suns icon which means she admits
something akin to a human presence how
do you think and she is like a human
well just walk smaller or so I get to
see these robots all over the place to
me it's one of the most lifelike
[Music]
and Hiroshi has an interesting
proposition for me that would test how
close to human I think Erica really is
you wanna be Ruby anomalous alright if I
was gonna kiss this room yes I would
as long as I can okay have you ever
kissed Erica no this is the Japan right
we are not in the United States right
Japanese never do that
my guess is that we're gonna have a huge
bar I tease for the robots we have a
huge variety for the car right
very cheap causing economic our right
button we also have a very origin in
abortion and this is a kind of a Ferrari
[Music]
[Music]
you